[Music]
we know that four and five are whole
numbers
what is four plus five it's nine nine is
also a whole number even the numbers 22
and 33 are whole numbers
what is 22 plus 33 you're correct it's
55 and 55 is also a whole number are you
getting a gist of what I'm trying to say
also if I add two whole numbers 350 and
620 the answer to that is again a whole
number
similarly 28,000 plus 50 9,000 also
result in a whole number whenever we add
any two whole numbers the resultant
number that we get is also a whole
number and this is the first property of
a whole number however instead of this
we say that whole numbers are closed
under addition this is just a
mathematical way of saying it this
statement is actually the same as this
if I add any two whole numbers the
number that I get will also be a whole
number
now here is a question for you to answer
our whole numbers closed under
subtraction pause the video and give it
a thought
first of all let's understand what the
question means what do we mean by closed
under subtraction it means that if we
take any two whole numbers and subtract
them then we will always get whole
number will this way always happen let's
try to find this out by subtracting any
two random whole numbers 35 minus 20 is
equal to 15 we subtracted two whole
numbers and we got whole number again
similarly one thousand minus 999 will
give us one a whole number again what
about five minus eight what will we get
when we subtract eight from five wait a
moment
can we even subtract eight from five no
we can't do that even if we try to
subtract them here's what we get a
negative number we are not talking about
negative numbers now you will learn that
in the future lessons but we know that
this is certainly not a whole number
hence we will term this subtraction as
invalid similarly if you subtract 100
from 50 the answer that you will get is
a negative number both numbers are not
whole numbers so we can say whole
numbers are not closed under subtraction
what about multiplication our whole
numbers closed under multiplication yes
they are closed under multiplication
when you multiply any two whole numbers
you will always get a whole number here
are a few examples to support this
argument 5 times 5 is 25 a whole number
1 times 1,000 is 1,000 a whole number
again let's involve the whole numbers 0
0 times 10 is what when you multiply any
number with 0 we get 0 again so it's 0
we take any two whole numbers and
multiply them the answer that we get
will always be a whole number here's a
quick recap of what we studied so far in
this video we learned that whole numbers
are closed under addition not closed
under
and closed under multiplication these
three are arithmetic operations that we
commonly use is there another one which
is the fourth most common operation that
you know of its division I'm sure that
you must have already guessed the next
question that I'm going to ask you our
whole numbers closed under division four
and two are whole numbers and if we
divide 4 by 2 we get a whole number
again but if we divide 6 by 5 the answer
we will get will be in decimals which is
not a whole number
similarly examples such as 3 divided by
12 4/9 will not result in whole numbers
hence we say that whole numbers are not
closed under division what is 0 divided
by 4 it's 0 and what is 4 divided by 0
is it also 0 or perhaps some other
number in order to understand this we
first need to be sure that we know the
meaning of division we have studied
arithmetic operations and the fact is
that among all the arithmetic operations
students find division to be the most
difficult one
what is division when we divide a number
8 but therefore what actually are we
doing imagine the scenario there are 8
chocolates and 4 people and we want to
distribute these 8 chocolates to 4
people such that everyone gets equal
number of chocolates how many chocolates
will a single person get each person
will get 2 chocolates how did we get
this to yes we divided 8 by 4 and that
gave us 2 or in other words we divided
the number of chocolates available
equally among all the people now let's
say instead of 4 there are two people
now how will we divide ate chocolates
between two people how many chocolates
will each person get you're absolutely
correct each one will get 4 chocolates
let's act a bit crazy now
let us divide eight chocolates equally
among zero people that is 8 divided by
zero does it even makes sense to divide
eight chocolates
amongst no one no it doesn't hence we
say this is undefined or in other words
any whole number divided by zero is
undefined on the same lines these are
all undefined quantities we will see
another property of whole numbers in the
next video
[Music]